what we're seeing right now play out
is uh
kind of the end of
imperialist foreign policy right it
doesn't make any sense anymore to
essentially colonize it makes no sense
we have icbm missiles we have uh
we we have you know submarines we we've
got satellites you know we have we have
global cl uh conflict technology where
you don't need these proxy wars to set
up pseudo borders and launch points
right so afghanistan was never about
afghanistan afghanistan was about a
launch point to get into the east if
there was ever a conflict to get into
russia to get into pakistan and then
into north korea and china right this
actually goes back to bush pre-911 he
ran on this thing called the road map to
peace one of the things that you know
with our propaganda system that goes
back to the bush cheney rumsfeld days um
he was going to go into iraq no matter
what he was going to finish the job that
his dad didn't finish for this road map
to peace this is how he was going to
solve the israel you're saying bush jr
yes
and then when 9 11 happened and
everybody knew it was coming from
afghanistan really saudi arabia too but
we never did anything with saudi arabia
um and iran never did anything with iran
we went into iraq and we we had weapons
of mass destruction all that stuff but
it ended up being part of this whole
original plan of the quote unquote road
map to peace where they were going to
basically
essentially try to colonize a strip
from the mediterranean sea all the way
through afghanistan and that would be
the basis of operations for them to
invade anywhere in the world right
but what we've seen
is democracies can't win long term i
don't think so i think stalin was right
i don't think we have the the stomach
for blood for war we shouldn't have been
there in the very first place everybody
knew we shouldn't have been there in the
first place all right and
we needed to find out
he was in pakistan right so we spent 20
years and trillions of dollars in
afghanistan right and
look man the
the thing i i feel our foreign policy
doesn't work because we can't xi jinping
is going to be in power until we die
we're going to have a new regime every
eight years every four years how can we
have how can we possibly as a nation
compete against the 30 40 50-year plan
how can we possibly compete against
somebody that has the resources and he
has the wherewithal and
the job security to have a 25 30 year
plan hey i'm not going to worry about
competing with america today in 1990 i'm
going to make sure i funnel so much
money into their media and their
education system that their children are
my allies and i'm still going to be in
power how do we compete against
something like that how do we compete if
the left and the right are so far
divided in our country that there's no
actual we talked about synergy there's
no synergy in our goals there's no
synergy in what we want right now
depending on where your political
ideology is we don't even live in the
same reality anymore right so i i i fear
this should not be a left or right thing
it absolutely is it's
like right like right off the bat you
know your reaction and it was it was a
good reaction don't get me wrong but
your reaction was to be like well trump
and then also biden so it was a left and
right thing to you well i'm not stating
the facts
i said specifically this is not
politically do you think anybody in
china is saying well this is a xi
jinping thing no he doesn't have to
worry about that we we cannot compete
against global powers that are
authoritarian in nature and dictatorial
because we don't have a standardized
foreign policy
we our foreign policy changes every four
years yeah well that's democracy for you
well the thing is then then guys pull
all the way out if you're not going to
do total war if it's not going to be von
klausewitz like you said if we're going
to allow the maccabees if we're going to
allow vietnam where all they have to do
is just outweigh public opinion we don't
have to fight we just run out wait
public opinion just drain them bleed
them out bleed them out drain them dry
and then when they're gone boom we're
we're coming back and anybody who ever
helped let me these foreigners ask you
guys a question let me ask you so i
interviewed this guy last week because
two weeks ago his name is david vine
okay
uh a liberal on the left openly said it
on the interview wasn't like he was
playing hey well i'm you know on both
sides he wrote a book called the united
states of war okay and uh it says a
global history of america's endless
conflict from columbus to the islamic
state he says in the last 245 years kai
what was the number he says u.s has uh
not been at war only 11 years i think
that was a number he said
11 years non-stop we've been at war from
two uh for the last two or four years
look at the amount of money we spend on
our defense budget i get that so here's
so then he goes into saying well you
know
here's how many military bases we have
here's how much money we're spending etc
etc okay
so i when i did the tax video about two
months ago remember remember the whole
tax video i did one of the things i
found that is the fact that u.s has 800
military bases in some 70-plus countries
right i got a question for you he's
saying we pull out of everywhere that's
what he's saying okay china's got one
military base and we know where that is
in djibouti right of course you're never
going to forget the name of that so they
had the bahamas the the military active
military bases djibouti right by the you
know the
right canal for obvious reasons
they rely 72 percent of their oil from
the middle east so they have to kind of
protect that fight we have like what 800
bases we have 800 bases so here's
remember here's a couple questions for
you here's a couple questions for you
um
what would what would happen if we
pulled out every military base in the
world
what would happen if we did it
immediately what would happen if we took
the next five years to say we're pulling
everything out not immediately the good
the bad the ugly i mean give me what
happens good if we pull out good is we
save a lot of money we save a lot of do
we though
potentially but there's going to be a
lot of backlash from that so let's go
there so number one we save money let's
just say because okay we save money
number two maybe we're not getting
involved in everyone's marital issues
kind of figured out we're not your
savior anymore give me the bad give me
the ugly here's the bad go ahead um
we're still living the we're still
catching the fallout of a post-cold war
foreign policy we had all those bases to
secure energy independence and they they
these people the you know the reagan
doctrine and uh you know rumsfeld after
that this was because the pending war
with russia any day we needed to make
sure our oil reserves we had we had it
all right now russia russia's been gone
we've we've never really pulled out of
that i don't believe in imperialism
because i believe in capitalism you
don't need to take over mexico to
extract resources you don't you don't
need to invade them you just put a
mcdonald's in a starbucks and you
extract resources for value capitalism
for all of the bs we hear from from the
communists capitalism stops imperialism
capitalism stops colonialism because you
don't need to spend human capital matter
of fact the more you kill people
wherever you are the more you destroy
infrastructure the harder it is to
extract wealth so instead of instead of
going in to a place and decimating it
and taking it over and then you have to
administrate it and spending trillions
of dollars you just come in and you're
like hey guys you ever had a whataburger
it's kind of good you're gonna love this
thing okay give me the bat what else is
the bat give me the bat and the ugly
that's what i'm interested in pulling
out the base if we pull that bar 800
millimeters end of that the end of that
thing is that we then use those bases
not for because we didn't need to fight
the cold war anymore we used it as
payoffs we've been paying people off
that's what that that was trump's
biggest mistake quote unquote is he
stopped the global bribery
he stopped he got us out of the paris
accord he got us out of the the climate
accord he got us out of the who we have
been giving taxpayer money to to
despots to totalitarian regimes to to
leaders for 30 years billions and
billions and billions of dollars of
taxpayer money we've basically been
buying peace we've been buying influence
if we pull that away like trump did he
pulled that money away the global the
global regime came and got rid of him
got rid of what the time magazine called
fortified the election whatever they got
rid of them you pull the bases away
i fear the power vacuum that's created
china comes in and just starts cutting
the checks
china comes in and starts doing what we
did i'll say something else something
that i remember we started addressing
when you did the tax video and uh we
talked about the different bases yeah is
that
we need to stop fighting
wars like we did
50 years ago and with these basic cyber
biases now it's all about cyber of
course bio warfare
um
obviously ransomware everything that's
going on with that that's where our
focus should be the the days of having
bases and fighting wars like from the
cold war days like gerard says i do
agree with we need to change our
approach so our old school approach in
afghanistan
um maybe
when look the afghanistan is we're not
just going are we out peace we're gonna
be moderating the situation maybe
there's a way to rather than troops on
the ground
figure out cyber warfare against the
taliban figure out how to take their
money figure out how to
destroy their infrastructure their way
naive way of thinking that but with that
something needs to change no no no no
let me explain to you what i mean by
naive way of thinking
okay
that works
if both sides are willing to negotiate
you think you're dealing with reasonable
people on the taliban zero so what makes
you think
they're willing to work with you so
here's a whole thing they're saying
they're interviewing they're saying oh
we understand are the last time we did
it didn't work we need to work with
women and women need to be able to go to
school
and the girl said so can they dress like
me no no they can't do like you they
have to cover their face why it's
islamic but nowhere in the bible nowhere
in the quran says that no no
you have to and he's like no we are
going to take care of girls it's like um
yeah okay so let's just say so some
people like wow that's great they're
gonna let take care of girls and women
and all this other stuff yeah um
this reminds me of what it was like when
we lived in iran okay i'm an october
1878 baby
shah was in power iran was doing good
middle east was at peace iran got along
with everybody iran got along with
israel iran got along with us iran had
relationships with pretty much everybody
around the world russia
us europe uk they were dealing with not
the iran that we know today no not at
all have you seen them
by the way iranian women if you go iran
type in 70s tapping iran in 70 kai
tapping iran
in 60s and 70s like people don't realize
the mountains skiing
sinatra going there everybody would go
to iran to party because it's kind of
like a an older erosion of dubai that's
it that's literally it that's iran
before the revolution yeah iran go to
that website there's a website that you
okay right there right there click on
that website right there go to that and
go to the pictures okay
this is iran pre
revolution go down so you can see the
pictures guys if you go a little lower
they should pop up one by one by one uh
okay that's the women of beautiful women
they cannot dress like that today that's
an iranian woman look at that right
they're showing cleavage
try showing it looks like the hippies of
the 70s well but this was iran
women had power women had that's a faro
zelda right there that's a very
legendary uh guy right there so
by the way close your eyes at him that's
that's that's iran dylan would be uh
would be fired up about all these
pictures right now that's that's sad and
more deeply moral of the story is this
iran is doing great and everybody
khomeini started calling the shah puppet
of what
america puppet of america oh my gosh
what a great that's iran by the way
skiing okay iran's mountain skiing is
one of the best in the world by the way
so people used to go there for vacation
right
and then fast forward to today fast
forward to today what's going on with
iran well jimmy carter similar situation
as biden well let's not get involved
kissinger we're going to help you shot
don't worry about it we're going to help
you we're going to help you hey i kind
of need help it's getting pretty crazy 9
million people revolted we're sorry we
can't help you how the hell do you go up
against nine million people you can't
the same scene you saw with helicopters
and planes landing type in khomeini iran
airport revolution type romani
k-h-o-k-h-o-m-e-i-n-i
uh i and i i and i yeah and then type in
uh revolution
revel revo
revelation yeah iran airport
okay look at this airport tell me what
this reminds you of taco images what
does this remind you of
okay
that's the airport him landing
okay they can't control any of it he
comes from air france to iran it's
absolute insanity biggest revolution in
this in the history of world nine
million iranians revolted over tapes
that romania was sending
from france to iran why did the people
of iran want the church because romani
said the shah is getting richer
iran's getting richer and that money
should be yours kai we can stop it that
money should be yours if you vote me and
i'll give you a free place to live
there's a message of it you should
listen to khomeini says i'm going to
give you free rice
free housing free everything if you get
me elected we are rich enough to be able
to do everything for you for free cheese
and the truth how much of this was
religion based
it wasn't religion it was always
socio-economic socio-economic let's turn
against this guy's becoming too rich
what happens they come in they take over
what happens iran
show show it's done half a
million people died in the 80s war
saddam hussein etc etc so here's the
point i'm trying to make to you
so for me when i'm talking to david vine
i said david you seem like a sweetheart
i mean i used to ward against him
because that's a qualified sweetheart
says we think we need to stop and we
need to stop with one i said i said so
here's a question for you this is i'm
taking a completely different angle with
it i said let me ask you a question
if you kill someone's father how long
does that boy think about the fact that
you killed his father i saw that clip by
the way that was he's never going to
forget he are you kidding me look what
are you talking about he's now you
killed my father you killed my
grandmother you feel my sister you
killed my brother my father coming after
you that's it's over yeah so now take
that story
times
50 000 people like that okay more than
that i'm just giving you a smile i'm
talking rage at that level
so you say we're gonna pull out because
we are now going to be
very peaceful type of regime and we're
not going to we're just going to change
it up it's what we're going to do you
know what that's kind of like that's
kind of like a football coach going from
a defensive team to an offensive team
and you're just a defensive guy you're
changing your strategy middle of a game
you're going to win you're a defensive
team are you saying that you think
there's going to be massive blow back
from the app just wait
just
wait
just wait the same people that they let
out of the whole human rights movement
that jimmy carter was on the same people
that let they let out from what he
called it the iranian human rights of
3000 that's what formatted i interviewed
the former taliban that is now an mi6
guy interviewed him a month ago six
weeks ago kai what was his name oman oh
amen and you should see some of the
stuff he's talking about eamon dean
eamon dean right
and you should see what he says about
what took place there's gonna be such
pushback with this because now here's
what happens you officially gave they
said well biden says well you know the
afghani military is strong
they have 300 000 soldiers the taliban
only has 75 000 really the taliban 75
000.
you know what's going to happen to
afghanistan it's a training ground it's
a recruiting camp they're going to
recruit and train recruit and train
they're angry
and they're by the way you know they
they released all the criminals from
prison
did you hear about that they they they
completely unloaded yeah exactly that's
the play they unleash the prisoners same
exactly they were all these are in iran
exactly and these people that were in
guantanamo bay nonetheless yeah well
this is you don't think they're freaking
angry this goes back to what we were
talking about but the point i'm trying
to make to you here's the point i'm
trying to make you i'm sitting there
saying we got 800 military bases right
and it cost us 50 billion a year to
manage this 800 military bases i'm
shocked that that's not a lot of money
that's it i thought it would be a bigger
number david vines that's only fair i'm
like only 50 billion that's not a lot of
money
so 50 billion to me i think 50 billion
is worth it if you ask me if it's only
50 billion i thought it would be a half
a trillion dollars i thought it would be
a massive number it's only 50 billion
all i'm saying is
this is not going to go away stay tuned
for something
pretty tragic to happen again that's
going to be at the levels of what we saw
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]